le mal ne dort pas
il attend quelque chose revient à l'
âge des ténèbres
le diable dans son armée tu sais que le monde
est brisé c'est la seule façon dont
j'ai regardé
il a dit que l'âge des héros ne reviendrait jamais
ne t'engage pas seul nous allons  fais ça
ensemble
[Musique]
je veux que tu m'écoutes perry parce que
je veux dire que
je rassemble une équipe de
personnes avec des capacités spéciales
tu peux être ce que tu veux être je
ne peux pas rester assis ici
et te regarder courir sur place  tu dois
courir plus vite que tu n'as jamais essayé
tu es brillant absolu le meilleur des
meilleurs
fais de ton propre avenir ton propre avenir
tout de suite
tu peux tourner le dos au monde
pour toujours
au-dessus ou en dessous de milliers d'années depuis que
notre peuple a parlé
le  première-née reine de sang bien-aimée j'ai
besoin de guerriers
tu ne peux pas avoir peur le temps est venu de
prendre la fierté de ta mère c'est une
mauvaise idée de
combattre le diable dans son armée je te connais